c'est quoi pour vous c'est
pas grand chose l'union européenne ces
28 pays
508 millions d'habitants 24 langues et
au milieu de tout ça le citoyen français
est ce qu'ils se sentent européens au
départ en 1951 la communauté européenne
ce sont six pays
6les économique avant tout ni pour la
paix
cette idée elle persiste dans le coeur
des français notamment elle avait dû
première élargissement en 1973 avant
l'europe des neufs ont chu là qu'il y a
rapprochement entre les peuples qui est
déjà effectif toujours en revanche s'ils
se sentir européen c'est connaître
l'europe
eh bien disons qu'en 1978 pour ces
jeunes alsaciens ce n'est pas gagné
je vous dit robert schuman ça vous fait
penser à quoi
c'est l'un des pères fondateurs de la
communauté européenne
18 19 c'était neuf à l'époque enfants ou
adultes à vrai dire la communauté
économique européenne c'est flou dans
les esprits aux techniques bien que
parfois pratiqué quotidien des gens je
ne sais pas s'ils sentent tellement
européen
je crois qu'ils s'en fichent un peu
royalement à ce qui les intéresse c'est
de passer librement la frontière pour
aller par exemple du champ du valais
le récent lancement à chair et leur
alcool leurs impératifs quelques mesures
plus concrètes de l'union font tout de
même éclore une conscience commune comme
le programme d'études erasmus en 1987
c'est beaucoup de jeunes qui qui se
ressemblent maintenant se sentir
européen c'est aussi se mobiliser pour
l'union en clair voter or en france s'il
ya bien un scrutin qu'il n'attire pas
les foules
ce sont les élections européennes en
huit votes depuis 1979
l'abstention a été de 39 % au plus bas
est au plus haut 59%
pourtant les politiques ont parfois fait
appel à des renforts de poids en 2005
jacques chirac mise tout sur un allié
europhile et rock'n'roll
je me sens européen parce que je voyage
continuellement et moi je suis bien
parti
ce soit l'état qui que ce soit
je
maroc
j'ai je me sens chez moi partout alors
que la communauté était le symbole fort
de la paix à ses débuts aujourd'hui les
français y sont ils encore attachés
selon un sondage réalisé fin 2010 8 59%
des citoyens se disent attachés à
l'europe
c'est moins que la moyenne européenne
65% et bien en-deça de nos voisins
allemands 80%
[Musique]